Film Courage: I think you’ve said previously
that you were hoping a writer would do
something new with the superhero format.
Has anything changed in the last few years?
Script Doctor, Writing Coach, and Author Daniel
Calvisi: I feel like there were more experimental
movies with superheroes a while back maybe 10
years ago than there are today probably because
they're there's so much money and there's so much
budget thrown into so much superhero material
maybe lower budget filmmakers and not exploring
that genre as much but they're definitely saying
there's audience fatigue with superhero movies and
shows and we'll see how that plays out I know the
studios and and streamers are worried about that
well I mean it would take such a budget though
to pull that off except for maybe the Greatest
American Hero the TV show I mean that was that's
different but most of this is just going to be
over the top special effects and and just well
I think there's room there for someone to tell a
really compelling human drama with someone who has
quote superpowers and maybe does something heroic
I think there is room for a unique Storyteller to
tackle that genre and just turn it on its head are
you still bored by some of the superhero action
films of today yeah definitely I'm getting more
bored by them actually and I have been although
I used to be a huge Marvel fan I mean I'm still
a Marvel fan I still actually collect Comics I
collect more DC Comics than Marvel I'm a Batman
fan but I think they're put Marvel's putting out
too much stuff and I'm some of it I'm not even
bothering to see in the theater I'm definitely
not bothering to see streaming shows I used to
watch every one of them and there's already been
a few that I haven't really watched which is just
they're just not compelling me and I see a lot
of the same tropes and recycled through various
movies and especially the action I mean there's
only so many ways you can shoot and stage Kung Fu
fight or something or a battle with two people who
can fly it's getting a bit stale I think but that
doesn't mean they can't turn it around it doesn't
mean they can't do something fresh in the same
way they did with like when Black Panther came
out I mean that was very fresh it had a cultural
perspective that they hadn't had before that and
there's always the opportunity to bring something
new into that world so is it really boiling down
to story it's lacking in story I think so story
I do think there is a visual element that could
could be played with they actually I've seen
people online criticize Marvel's color palette
in their movies they say DC movies have better
better color grading they just pop better visually
and I never really thought that but it might be
a part of it they might want to play a little bit
more with visuals with genre tropes sometimes
they want to take a character and kind of put
them into a genre that you wouldn't normally think
of there was a Marvel show I think it was it that
one with the werewolf and there was like a black
they shot it like a black and white kind of old
horror movie and it kind of came and went maybe it
didn't click but when they can do experimentation
with that I think that's good I also think that
they're relying too much on comedy I mean believe
it or not I want to take my superheroes more
seriously I don't want every one of them to
be cracking jokes and for us to be making fun of
them I know it may sound silly but like Thor is a
serious character to me I don't want it constantly
the whole movie they're making fun of Thor I just
think there's there's too many jokes and and
they're falling flat a little bit what do you
want from superhero movies as a fan and what do
you want from superhero movies as an analyst well
as a fan I think we all want to see characters
that we loved in the comic books come to life but
the thing is fans usually want to see them come
to life how they envision them like if there's a
change of a race or a gender they say that's not
the Captain Marvel I grew up with but story-wise I
do think really good writing is huge a good story
is huge and a director who can bring that story to
life is huge I think they need to take their world
very seriously in a lot of instances they do need
to change less from the comic book Miss Marvel was
a good example of that I was a big fan of Kamala
Khan who's the she's a Pakistani teenager who
lives in Jersey City and when she came out in the
comic books it was very fresh they hadn't had many
superheroes of color they hadn't had many teenage
girl superheroes and certainly not a Pakistani
Muslim in America and so and a lot of people were
up in arms like this isn't my superhero I grew
up with but I started reading the comics and they
were really great and I really was rooting for her
and I really liked seeing that culture and I but
she had a very specific backstory with how she got
her powers and they made the Disney Plus show and
they changed that and they they changed her powers
because they were kind of close to Reed Richards A
Fantastic Four like she can grow big and she can
stretch her limbs and stuff so they thought that
would be too close this is what I've heard then
it' be too close to a Fantastic Four movie when
they do that so they changed it too much they
also made I think they kind of had a too much
of an emphasis on a political point in history
that they were tying in and they brought that
into her backstory and they made it an element
behind her powers and so in that instance I felt
they changed too much from the comic book and
I felt like it diluted the story and the story
elements that made it so fun and so compelling for
me but I mean maybe maybe it gathered a whole new
audience of other people who weren't middle-aged
gen xers still reading comic books don't write
for the lowest common denominator write for your
intelligence WR something that you would want to
see right something that is smart that you would
think was smart and clever and compelling a lot
of new writers are like I'm just going to write
one of these Hollywood movies these commercial
Hollywood movies they're so dumb and they have car
chases and they have they don't adhere to physics
and they're throwing a sex scene and some violence
and that'll make a great script right well that's
not going to impress the readers in the business
who read hundreds of scripts all the time avoid
the cliches avoid the tropes do it your own way
and try to make your story stand out because
it's not like something else it's Unique but at
the same time make sure it it ticks off certain
timings or or like you said before fits into a
mold it can't just be a free-for-all yeah I think
structurally you you want to at least learn the
industry standard form first before you experiment
with it and you do want to be aware of it like I
said you don't want to write a 150 page screenplay
when today scripts are maximum 120 Pages and most
of them are less so you do want to know the form
you do want know that usually act one is around
30 pages you do want to know that usually act two
the end of act two is going to be in the 80 to
90 page range and it's usually going to involve
the main character really hitting bottom and kind
of the conflict spiking more than ever and then
there's a turn in the story there's something
shocking maybe opens a gateway they go through
that gateway and that gets them into act three
which is new dramatic territory and the stakes
are raised and there's a ticking time clock and
we're on the edge of our seats wondering what's
going to happen in that climax and if they're
going to achieve their goal that may sound like a
lot of of strictures and too generic of guidelines
but there's actually a million things you could do
within those guidelines and they're done all the
time by great movies and great TV shows all genres
all types of tones and themes subject matter
I like that so yeah so there's structure but
within that structure within each little part you
have freedom yeah and it's your job as a writer
to execute something that does feel fresh that
is surprising to that reader but ideally you do
stay within those structural parameters you don't
have to adhere to it exactly if you feel like your
act two ends on page 72 and not page 90 that's
okay I mean ultimately it's do we want to turn
the page do we want to keep reading do we want
to keep watching this show keep me entertained.